good morning John I would like to do for
you a historic reenactment of the moment
when I read the title of your video from
last week what a lovely day
I am not currently experiencing any
sources of broad anxiety let's go see if
John's uploaded his video
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm fine now I mean how does this all
end it ends in death John you gave me a
whole word for it that I forgot it's
gonna bug me so I'm gonna text you
what's the word for the philosophy
Lusaka word or death and talking about
death at you use sometimes I mean the
translation algorithms are getting so
good you know John Hill right back he
knows what I mean first of all survey
results say people are cool with us
taking three weeks of vacation I don't
know how I'm gonna do that I'm not
really set up for that in my mind
they're being space for flexibility I
don't know if that's that's good for me
I need to know exactly what I have to do
so I think that I'm going to schedule my
vacation days like very far in advance
to not give myself the possibility that
like oh maybe it's gonna be this week if
I don't have any good ideas no I need
the pressure and I think it's
interesting that you were like how how
do we get a little bit of vacation
whereas I have spent the last three
weeks being like I'm think I need to
upload a video about Donuts on Hanks
channel what about the FDA's new
nutritional label requirements I think I
need to weigh in on that eschatology
there's my big bro it's the word you're
thinking about but it's the whole human
apocalypse not just individual death
eschatological anxiety is fear of
apocalyptic events but that stands how
is this going to end you know it it will
eventually but I have a lot more to talk
about today for example the fact that I
have just left this hammer that I hit a
router with on the floor for that long
it I have a problem with tidying up does
anyone want this hammer I'm gonna hide
it in the bushes by the Big Dipper ice
cream shop and if you come by it'll be
there okay John I'm almost done signing
pieces of paper and the pieces of paper
they gave me freedom of the UK editions
of my book were different and had a
weird cool stop-motion effect when I
sped up the video each page is a little
bit different in the Carl's faded an out
and at one point one of them blinks
whoever at Orion which is my UK
publisher thought of that that's amazing
and I did not expect that to work that
well when you told me that you were
doing it I was like yeah probably won't
look his but it looks so cool out John
you just won't stop texting me
out various death things I also John
have an audiobook narrator I almost wish
that I had been less involved because it
gave me so much anxiety they were all so
good all of the people we had to choose
from but ultimately it was very
subjective it was the person when I was
listening to it I felt like I was
listening to April gave me those
goosebumps made me feel like the person
I created was talking to me which was
both like beautiful and emotional but
also like a little upsetting I'm like
kind of uncanny
but the narrator of my audio book
there's actually two of them the main
one is Kristen see she was in orange and
the oranges in the new black blacklist
house of cards the other narrator of my
audio book so there is at a point in the
book a switching of perspectives for one
chapter and I will be doing that chapter
and so I feel very good about this
happening and I cannot wait to start
getting into the weeds of getting the
audiobook man and John finally to cap
off this video the comments that people
left on your video after you said this
what do you get out of vlogbrothers
videos we're just so like life giving to
me you know forever that if I need a
little lift me up a little kick kick me
in the pants I can go to the comments of
that video and just read a little bit so
thanks John and thanks everybody who
left those comments it means a huge
amount John I'll see you on Tuesday